resulta que resolver problemas de campo
eléctrico se vuelve más difícil cuando
hay varias cargas en realidad esto no
debería ser así pero a las personas se
les complica esto cuando hay varias
cargas involucradas digamos que esta es
la pregunta cuál es la magnitud y
dirección del campo eléctrico neto
creado a la mitad del camino entre las
dos cargas el campo eléctrico neto es el
campo eléctrico total aquí tenemos una
carga de +8 nano cool oms y una carga de
-8 nano cool oms y están separadas una
distancia de 6 metros de centro a centro
pero lo que queremos saber es cuál es el
campo eléctrico neto que ambas cargas
crean justo aquí cada una de estas
cargas va a crear un campo eléctrico en
este punto y si sumamos estos campos
eléctricos como vectores cuál será el
campo eléctrico neto aquí al principio
podríamos pensar que aquí va a ser cero
es muy tentador pensar que el campo
eléctrico aquí va a ser igual a cero
porque
tenemos una carga de más 8 malo cool oms
y una carga de menos 8 nano cool oms y
estas deberían cancelarse aquí cierto
pero hay que ser cuidadoso esto no es
cierto y para saber por qué primero
tenemos que dibujar cómo se vería el
campo eléctrico de cada una de estas
cargas en este punto de acá el campo
eléctrico generado por nuestros 8 nano
colores positivos va a ser creado
radialmente hacia afuera de esta carga
así que va a ir hacia la derecha y
cuando quiero encontrar el campo
eléctrico de esta carga no toma en
cuenta la otra carga en el momento en el
que estoy calculando el campo eléctrico
de la carga azul me carga amarilla ni
siquiera existe en mi mente cuando me
digo cuál va a ser el campo eléctrico
creado por esta carga va a hacer este
sin importar si esta carga amarilla
existe o no y ahora hago lo mismo con
esta otra carga me preguntó cuál será el
campo eléctrico generado por esta carga
negativa en este punto
y aquí voy a pretender que no existe
esta carga positiva acá las cargas
negativas crean un campo eléctrico que
va radialmente hacia adentro de la carga
y en este caso radialmente hacia adentro
me va a apuntar hacia la derecha por lo
que estos campos no se cancelan la carga
negativa me crea un campo eléctrico
radialmente hacia adentro que va hacia
la derecha y la carga positiva me genera
un campo eléctrico que va radialmente
hacia afuera de ella que también va
hacia la derecha así que estos campos no
sólo no se van a cancelar sino que se
van a sumar va a ser el doble de la
magnitud estos vectores los sumamos ya
que apuntan a la misma dirección y la
contribución de cada uno de ellos va a
ser en total el doble de la magnitud de
uno solo por lo que no siempre es el
caso que el campo eléctrico de una carga
negativa se va a cancelar con el campo
eléctrico de una carga positiva ya que
estos campos eléctricos podrían apuntar
a la misma dirección
así que hay que tener cuidado y como
encontramos este campo eléctrico neto
bueno lo primero que voy a hacer es
decir que este campo eléctrico neto va a
apuntar hacia la derecha todo va en la
dirección x en esta dirección horizontal
y será la suma de cada uno de estos
campos eléctricos primero será el campo
eléctrico azul que es el positivo más el
campo eléctrico de la carga negativa acá
por la carga positiva entre r al
cuadrado y esto le sumamos la carga
negativa que es la amarilla más cara por
q que es la carga negativa entre r al
cuadrado ponemos valores está acá
siempre va a ser 9 por 10 a la 9 y la
carga azul es de más 8 nano cool oms na
no es lo mismo que 10 a la menos 9 me
gusta usar nano porque este 10 a la
menos 9 se cancela con este 10 a la 9 y
cuál distancia es la que voy a poner
aquí mucho
a veces las personas pondrían 6 aquí
pero no es lo que queremos piensen en
ello quiero el campo eléctrico neto en
medio de las dos cargas por lo que la
distancia que me interesa es la que va
desde la carga hasta el punto en donde
quiero encontrar el campo eléctrico que
en este caso es de 3 metros la distancia
desde la carga hasta el punto en donde
quiero encontrar el campo eléctrico es
de 3 metros y no de 6 metros si
quisiéramos conocer cuál es el campo
eléctrico que estas cargas generan entre
ellas entonces si pondría 6 metros pero
no es lo que me preguntan aquí aquí
queremos conocer el campo eléctrico neto
que se encuentra en medio de las dos
cargas así que aquí pongo 3 metros y no
me olvido de elevarlo al cuadrado ahora
tengan cuidado porque el hecho de que mi
carga sea positiva no quiere decir que
su contribución al campo eléctrico neto
en este punto vaya a ser positiva
también no pueden confiarse en él
signo de esta carga para ver si la
contribución es positiva o negativa
tengo que dibujar el vector que
representa la contribución de esta carga
en este punto y en este caso el campo va
hacia la derecha por lo que la
contribución también va hacia la derecha
y esta es la dirección que típicamente
decimos que es positiva así que es por
esto que decimos que todo este término
va a ser positivo y ahora el otro
término podría poner más o menos porque
todavía no sé si será positivo o
negativo así que lo dejamos a un lado
por el momento esto será 9 por 10 a la 9
y la carga en este caso es menos 8 nano
cool oms pero no voy a poner el signo
negativo de la carga aquí y chispas se
me olvidó poner los cool oms en este
otro lado y nuevamente la distancia que
me interesa es desde la carga hasta el
punto en donde estoy midiendo el campo
eléctrico nuevamente en este caso es de
3 metros y lo escribo aquí sin olvidarme
de elevarlo al cuadrado
esta contribución es positiva o negativa
no me puedo confiar en el signo de la
carga para determinar esto tengo que
dibujar el campo y darme cuenta de en
qué dirección se encuentra en este caso
va hacia la derecha que establecimos
como la dirección positiva así que esta
contribución también será positiva ambas
van en la misma dirección por lo que se
van a sumar por lo que el campo
eléctrico total va a ser la suma de
estas dos vamos a hacerlo 3 al cuadrado
es 99 dividido entre 9 nos da 1 por lo
que nos queda 8 newtons colom y este
término es lo mismo 9 se divide entre 9
10 a la 9 se cancela con 10 a la menos 9
y nos quedan ocho newtons colom cada una
de las cargas contribuye 8 newtons colom
al campo eléctrico en este punto lo que
significa que el campo eléctrico neto
total será de 16 newtons por colom en
ese punto
esta es la magnitud del campo eléctrico
neto en el punto en medio de las dos
cargas y cuál es la dirección de este
campo pues es hacia la derecha ambos
vectores apuntan hacia la derecha por lo
que esta es la dirección del campo
eléctrico neto y además es el doble de
la magnitud de cada uno de ellos y como
en este caso ambas contribuciones son
iguales pues podrían evitar escribir uno
y simplemente multiplicar por dos el
otro término pero en este caso
escribimos todo explícitamente para que
se dieran cuenta de cómo resolver esto
al final nos quedamos con 16 newtons
colom que apuntan hacia la derecha y
como cambiaría esto si yo en lugar de
tener una carga negativa que tuviera una
carga positiva de 8 nano culos pues ya
no crearía un campo eléctrico que apunta
hacia la derecha sino que crearía un
campo eléctrico que apunta hacia la
izquierda
pues las cargas eléctricas positivas
generan un campo eléctrico que va
radialmente hacia afuera de ellas así
que el campo eléctrico de esta carga
iría hacia la izquierda lo que quiere
decir que cuando yo calculé su
contribución al campo eléctrico neto
este término va a ser negativo porque va
en dirección a la izquierda que es por
convención nuestra dirección negativa
aún cuando es una carga positiva su
contribución al campo eléctrico en este
punto va a ser negativa porque apunta en
la dirección negativa y esto me daría un
campo eléctrico igual a cero si esta
carga fuera positiva todo esto sería
igual a cero porque tendríamos 8
positivo menos 8 va a ser igual a 0 por
lo que el campo eléctrico se cancelaría
por completo en el medio
así pues tengan cuidado en el signo que
le ponen a cada contribución no se dejen
llevar por el signo que tienen la carga
en la fórmula siempre escriban las
cargas como positivas aún cuando sean
negativas
pues deciden el signo dependiendo de
cuando dibujen el campo eléctrico hacia
qué sentido se dirige cada contribución
si van hacia la derecha pondríamos un
signo positivo en el término y si va
hacia la izquierda pondríamos un signo
negativo ya que hacia la izquierda es la
dirección negativa en resumen para
encontrar el campo eléctrico neto con
varias cargas tenemos que dibujar el
campo eléctrico generado por cada una de
estas cargas de forma independiente en
el punto de interés usamos esta fórmula
para encontrar la magnitud de la
contribución de cada una de las cargas y
después decidimos cuál será el signo de
la contribución de cada una de estas
cargas positivo o negativo con base en
la dirección del campo eléctrico y no en
el signo de las cargas sumamos todas las
contribuciones y esto nos dará el campo
eléctrico neto en este punto